all that young women now see is and this
is a lot of by the way programming from
social media from corporate media safe
to them means you're not going to get an
STI
that's it oh you're not going to get
pregnant you're not going to get an STI
you're going to no STDs everything's
good okay safe
why don't can we branch that word out
for a minute though because safe to me
doesn't just mean physical safety right
in terms of okay I walk away and I don't
have any baggage from this experience
physically and that I'm not walking away
with herpes
right it also means emotional safety is
that lifestyle if you have a daughter is
that lifestyle a promiscuity safe for
her it's not
take the physical component out mentally
is that safe no she's gonna constantly
feel broken inside